welcome to this video playing brady
harder Brady off mm-hmm okay let's see
your T's doing check yeah the carrier's
defense be sure check one check that's a
very very solid way to play difficult
for y2 to do anything can play hair d 5
is even more solid let's say these
successes is even even more yeah more
fighting alternative going for for an e5
based setup ok it's going to seven let's
see yeah I want to control all those
crucial squares
so that the Knights don't have any any
direct outposts of squares to go to so
let's see if I can win some space on the
queenside a three takes takes rook takes
rook takes bishop h three ad that very
badly timed beforehand that's bad that's
really bad yeah yeah this is very very
very awful if I have to do that but
there's no other move b5 is what stop
taking that's the strange ok now of
course he has to take to damage my pawn
structure
and do we know why here why he avoided
that
hmm now i can again recapture with the
apron and keep my my pawn structure
intact that's very good okay my dev form
really yeah this is neither for it's not
going to work but you might do it anyway
Oh Bishop h3 is a move should we should
think first and then move young
nigerians was simply refuting this night
age five but no he can take well now it
is working okay okay I cannot take night
f4 really falling into this the simple
trap now we can just go back to f6 it
has want to pawn them very bad play I
mean
to any other square energy one or
something then night h5 is is just
useless he has to retreat with with no
nothing gained am absolutely nothing
okay just has wonder the age three point
absolutely nothing at least that was
quicker haven't wasted any time on those
rubbish moves hey I can get some pre
moves and even don't think that actually
that taking on on b5 was such a great
idea this gives me some additional
possibilities like this
what is he going for 95 on hmm or f5 I
don't know okay i want to have quincy
six available anyway okay but that's not
so nice he has to play the Queen now
Queen where da dough is seven now k can
play the Queen to d8 is Evan trading you
cannot okay now look at seven Bishop a
six will be very tricky or Bishop g4 me
in this position the the pawn down is
not another problem what is this okay if
it takes on d5 I have Bishop c4 right
rook checks I have Bishop g4 so d4
Knight f6 or what exactly is the point
hmm yeah what is so this is what is the
most precise way to play this this is
also most
yeah all here this is for Bishop a 6 ok
so Bishop a 60s look I am hmm
yeah that's it says that's worse then
takes here why okay i'm giving up I
don't expect any move which is probably
from the my own fault I don't I don't
expect any office moves
hmm this for the check oh I don't don't
understand that 93 m this was the idea
so I cannot play maybe this one kicking
kicking the night back for Bishop g4
check
okay so he's attacking this if one night
III haha ok time morning
yeah it is really dangerous if he can if
he gets this check on f2 when it is
dangerous but this should be all right
check
come on have five okay yeah this is this
this should be good right Luke age seven
mate no okay check that wasn't an
especially good game reserve I'm glad to
have to at least have wanted wow that
was really bad him it was really it
before was especially especially awful
this is a just a normal position with
nothing special going on I have to play
normal slow moves a three or I don't
know some small moves it's it's probably
slightly it's equal or maybe slightly
better for white due to the space but
nothing special but this is just just
awful you are a five I cannot do this M
check because of this tactic the NDF I
don't know why he didn't take on before
this is just just much easier and then
let's block this block this for a while
I don't know maybe I'm still okay yeah
but of course I don't want this yeah now
I keep the gap this is just very stupid
yeah this runs into Bishop a dream I
have to play something else is it
something else night shift one maybe mm
and then he is back and then I can can
go from here I am NOT neither 34 draw
baby Bishop f3 and then 92 or whatever
it's just a normal game but this is just
terrible blunder it just gives up gives
up this pawn for for absolutely nothing
and he surprised me by allowing this
structure and this is not not that clear
i have this this entry point on a 6
which she cannot take on a six
and then I was pretty much shocked that
he took here because after that i really
should be more than ok the week c7 porn
withdrew k7 bishop a 60 Bishop g4 should
be should be at least ok for me I mean I
was thinking I was much better but this
is probably just my my natural optimism
Knight f6 yeah I didn't really know how
to how to play here very difficulty you
always suffers from this is having
permit those nights are dangerous check
yeah now i'm winning them he has to do
this with an equal position computer
says equal now maybe i don't really get
the bishop in there i mean this is this
is go k and i can insert this but it
doesn't help really i don't get to e6 i
can give this check but what exactly is
the point i don't get anywhere and this
is of course was so nice now i got in a
four and he cannot defend the sea point
check now yeah yeah i'm relatively
easily winning but a very bad game yeah
okay well thanks for watching